hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the world rapids championship
where we have a four-way tie uh nippo
karwana abdusatorov and magnus carlson
are sharing first place with nine points
uh but going into uh the final round uh
nevo and caruana drew their game after
like maybe five moves uh as uh
it seems that fabi did not know that uh
only two people can go into tie breaks
he probably thought maybe more people
can go into tie breaks and he thought a
draw in the final round was a good
result but this automatically means that
he can no longer
be a contender for first place so that
leaves uh magnus hikaru playing here and
abdusator
all depending on how his game against
duda goes so let's check it out it's
quite quite an interesting game and a
lot uh has happened so here hikaru opens
with the d4 we have d5 by magnus c4
we have e6 knight to f3 knight to f6 and
now knight to c3 we have bishop to e7 so
the three knights variation of the
queens can be declined uh bishop to f4
and the magnus castles we have e3 and
magnus strikes with c5 we have d
captures on c5 bishop captures on c5 and
queen to c2 such as developing pieces
nothing out of the ordinary knight to c6
and now rook to d1 uh this is uh this is
actually a position from the world chase
championship uh a match uh crossing head
against caruana where magnus first
played a3 and if you remember then we
had queen to a5 fabio went into this uh
very sneaky line and after magnus played
rook to d1 there was a rook to d8 that
glass shattering
move that uh magnus really really took
magnus by surprise but here hikaru
avoids the a3 move he goes rook to d1
right away and magnus now doesn't go
queen to a5 which is the standard move
in this position pretty much everyone
plays queen to a5 here he plays queen to
b6 and now uh what do you do here well
uh it's a very it's a very interesting
move obviously you can play knight to a4
but just queen to a5 check so you you
don't really gain anything by this so
instead we have bishop to e2 hikaru
doesn't seem to be familiar with this so
he just wants to castle as soon as
possible and now magnus strikes in the
center with the d4 he wants to create
some imbalances in the position and get
winning chances even if it's with the
black piece so he captures on d4 knight
captures we have knight captures bishop
captures and hikaru castles to safety we
have bishop to d7 by magnus and now uh
there is a game where queen to d2 was
played but here we have bishop to f3 and
it is now only as a move 14 that we have
a completely new game interestingly
magnus is up some five to six minutes on
the clock hikaru is down to uh 10
minutes whereas magnus has some 16
minutes on the clock so more than when
he started with uh so he is um uh well
within um uh uh well uh
known territory so here we have rook
eight to d8 and now uh hikaru strikes
with b4 he says there's no uh point in
waiting with this move or preparing it
with with a move like a3 uh because if
queen captures on b4 the bishop here is
hanging so of course we can't play that
and you always have to be careful of c5
coming so magnus plays a bishop to c6 he
attacks the light square bishop here and
now bishop captures on c6 and now magnus
is the one who spent nearly five minutes
in this move uh he thought about queen
captures on c6 but this is um uh well
two to two drawish of a move so he
played b captures in c6 this brings
imbalance into the position and now
anything can be played here it's eight
minutes for magnus seven minutes for
hikaru and here we have knight to e2
attacking carlson's bishop here we have
e5 by magnus and now you could go back
with bishop to d2 but hikaru plays
knight captures on d4 we have e captures
on the four magnus gets a pass pawn and
now bishop to g5 here was a very
interesting moment where hikaru could
have gone from bishop to d6 attacking
the rook and well here just
if you don't want to move the rook you
could even go for rook captures c5 and
the queen captures on b4 this isn't bad
for black and now let's say rook b1 we
attack the queen before we capture back
queen to a3 now rook b3 and now magnus
would give up the queen here with queen
capture some b3 a captures and d3 and we
would have this completely insane game
where magnus would have a knight and the
rook for a queen for example queen to c3
we're going to play rook d5 bring the
other rook into the game and hopefully
push that pass pawn
but it's a very tricky move to calculate
with so little time on the clock so he
car goes bishop to g5 pins in the knight
and prepares to capture at least he will
have some queen f5 queen captures an f6
action where he can at least force a
draw so here queen captures on b4 by
magnus bishop captures on f6 g captures
and now queen to f5
asking magnus what do you do here and in
fact it's perfectly fine to capture the
pawn it is uh it's really the best move
in the position because after queen
captures you can play queen e6 and if
queen g5 check queen to g6 uh blocks
check and you are enjoying your extra
pawn uh however here magnus played rook
f to e8 and now hikaru played queen
captures on f6 interestingly you could
also just play queen g4 check and pick
up the d4 pawn also also possible but it
seems hikaru missed this it's uh it's
the last round of the world rapid
championship so i guess both of them are
extremely excited so queen captures on
f6 was played and now queen to d6 magnus
offers a queen trade and he wants to go
into a rook and pawn in game queen g5
check magnus plays queen to g6 and now
f4 uh this is how hikar wants to trade
he wants to get the open a semi-open f
file for the rook and now uh magnus
could try to kick away the queen or or
force a trade on his own terms but he
accepts the queen trade f captures and
now rook to e5 goes after the pawn but
hikaru plays rook to f4 he goes after
this pawn and magnus prefers to keep the
pawn so he doesn't want to trade and he
doesn't want to play c5 and allow h4
instead he plays d3 he wants to have an
active game and now hikaru plays rook to
d2 it's very interesting if you just
play h4 now we're gonna play rook to e2
and the distance is now a very very
active rook attacking this spawn now d2
is also coming so instead hikaru first
place rook to d2 doesn't allow rook to
e2 and now rook captures on g5 we have
rook to f3 this spawn will now fall and
now rook to d4 going after the c for
pawn and here hikaru is already down to
a minute and a half whereas magnus has
some four and a half minutes on the
clock so here we have rook captures on
d3 rook captures on c4 and now rook the
g3 uh offering a rook trade and hikaru
is confident that he can hold the same
game being down only a pawn so rook c5
this is how magnus will trade we have
rook captures rook captures and now rook
to a3 going after the a7 pawn and now
magnus defends it with a5 we have rooked
the c3 going after this pawn now rook to
b5 so we're gonna give up this pawn and
we will try to advance uh this pawn so
rook captures on c6 now comes rogue b2
we go after the pawn a4 now comes rook
b4 and now king to f2 magnus grabs the
a4 pawn and now it's the past a pawn
against the hikaru's rook
so let's see what happens we have rook
to a6 very principled you have to put
the rook behind the pass pawn and now h5
uh we have h4 and now rook to f4 with
check we have king to e3 and rook to f5
magnus um defends
his position like this and now he will
try to get the king into the game maybe
push f6 maybe make some progress we have
g3 king to g7 ended now king to e4
attacking the rook we have rook to b5
and now king to f4
we have f6 by magnus now comes rook to
a7 check king to g6 and now king the e4
so uh this is uh this is actually uh a a
a a completely drawn position but if you
play correctly and well that's easier
said than done as both of them are
extremely low on the clock rook before
check king to f3 we have rook b3 check
king f4 uh rook to a3 now magnus will
try to push the the past a pawn we have
rook to c7
and now we have a4 we have broke back to
a7 now comes rook to a2 magnus tries to
make progress this way rook to a5 and
now we have a3 we have king f3 now comes
rook to a1 we have king to f2 now comes
f5 so
trying to make a little bit of a
progress here and also if the white rook
starts checking us we're going to go all
the way to b7 so here we have rook a6
check king to f7 and now king the g2 a
most interesting maneuver by hikaru king
the e7 now comes rook a5 going after the
pawn here king to e6 and now king to h2
magnus delivers a check here with rook
to a2 check and he carl plays king to h3
and now this is a very dangerous square
for the king because the king is now
completely cut off from the game uh we
have king of six by magnus rook to a8
and now comes king to e5 we have rook to
a4 and now king the d5 and here he carl
plays rook to f4 goes after the pawn
then he wants to grab this pawn and this
is in fact a winning position for magnus
but it requires a super precise move so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is rook
to e2 this is the only move that wins
the game point being that after rook
captures an f5 check you can play rook
to e5 and now of course after rook to f2
uh defending the a2 square now we play
king to c4 and there's really nothing
white can do king b3 a2 is coming and
that's it this is how we win the game
however magnus played king to e6 uh he
missed this opportunity and now we have
rook to f3 by hikaru king e5 rook the e3
check king to d4 and now rook to f3
and now we have king back to e4 the
problem is uh you can't really make any
progress here if you go with king to c4
then you could even capture on f5 and
there's really not nothing you can do
at some point uh you can even capture
the pawn and maybe even you know give up
the rook for this pawn the two connected
past pawns will be enough to uh to
counter the rook or many uh
possibilities are
uh present here so instead king to e4 we
have rook there for czech king to e3 and
now rook captures on f5 we have rook to
a1 now hoping to get a2 and the rook to
h1 chicken but hikaru quickly goes back
king to g2 uh we have uh rook to a to
check king the h3 and he was in this
position on move 66 that uh hikaru and
the magnus agreed to a draw
as there is nothing more to be done here
if you try a2 there is no way to deliver
any any check and there's uh well
just rook a5 and you don't really have a
move here if king e4 even g4 is possible
captures h5 and now it's even white
who's uh uh you know uh threatening to
uh
promote the dh pawn so uh yeah after
after this king stage to remove they
agreed to a draw and what does this mean
for the tournament where there are a
couple of people tied for first place uh
i don't know if um
the exact standings are are done yet but
yeah it would seem that magnus is out of
the competition for first place and uh
as it would seem here at least on their
table base it seems that it will be uh
abdusatoro versus um yani palmashi
fighting for for first place in the tie
breaks but uh
we're going to cover that in the next
video depending on what what they decide
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh the tough tough move
to miss this um uh rook to e2 but it was
a chance for magnus to win the entire
thing he missed it and even
uh if he missed it then you know it's
not an easy move to find uh so i did
there you have it
uh so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed this uh little
rook and pawn in the game tutorial i
would like to thank catherine malta jack
schroeder uh jeffrey ryden or evgeny
brisken and david kimura for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day